hi everybody I'm Jonathan Sean and today
I got another tactical challenge for you
so when you see the image on your screen
go ahead pause your video and see if you
can solve it so this position it is
white to move I will go ahead and give
you guys a hint today if you haven't
already figured it out I'm trying to
take advantage of the fact that the
Queen doesn't have a whole lot of
squares that she can go to she's a
little bit closed in our territory so
see if you can somehow take advantage of
that fact here comes the answer the best
move in this position is rook to e5
interfering with the Queen's path and
making a threat I won't tell you what it
is right away but let's just look at
what happens if we play the most direct
move we just take your rook hopefully
you can see well white should play in
this position the move that traps the
queen is g3 and the Queen doesn't have
anywhere to go so the best you could do
is at least get another piece for it and
here white has won some material going
back if you see that you're about to get
trapped you may think you're clever and
perhaps you want to try and move like h5
not tempted by the exchange and I just
create a square so my queen can retreat
back to h6 well now still g3 is a strong
move because after you go back to h6 we
can grab the pawn on a5 now the knight
is hanging and when you retreat the
night among another move we can take on
f5 and then take on b7 and we have two
pawns for the exchange and a completely
dominant position
another very crafty move that you might
try going back to this position after
with the e5 just a move Bishop to d3
this also might be a confusing way to
try to confuse your opponent but it
should also be insufficient after a move
like g3 let's try this crafty move
Bishop to c2 well white here again gets
a great position after first taking on
c2 then trading the Queens
and here again white is one for material
and has a better position thank you
everybody for watching congrats to
everybody that was able to get this one
right as always hit like share subscribe
we'll see you next week for another
tactical challenge